[Music]
foreign
for Google Cloud cortex framework and
today I'm excited to talk about how data
goes from Zero to Hero with Google Cloud
cortex data foundation and how cortex
data processing templates help you
kick-start your data and insights
journey in previous videos
we covered how Google Cloud cortex
framework delivers not just a reference
architecture to solve business problems
but also provides solution content
templates and deployment accelerators
centered on a data Foundation built on
bigquery
specifically cortex data Foundation
includes predefined data processing
scripts and data models for strategic
data sources like Google sap Salesforce
and more
but how can I get started with this
content you might ask well everything
starts with data as long as data is
landed in bigquery in its raw format
with the same granularity as it is in
the source the predefined cortex
templates and content will connect and
work
for example for sap we assume table by
table replication and for Salesforce we
expect data as it is produced by the
apis we call the bigquery data set where
the source data lands the raw data set
once landed depending on how the
integration tool captures and processes
changes from Source into bigquery
some data requires for the processing
for example is it just append or does it
does the solution perform merge or
absurds
we call this process CDC for change data
capture
to make sure cortex predefined data
models have the latest version of Truth
for reporting we provide data processing
scripts that can help handle the CDC
process as well as the mapping of
different field names or formats we call
the bigquery data set where this process
data lends the CDC process data set this
data is now reporting ready reflecting
the latest records in the right format
from here cortex data Foundation
predefined mod data models can be used
it's important to note that some
integration tools may land data directly
into the CDC process data set but cortex
processing scripts can help you if the
integration tool has not taken care of
the change processing already we
recommend lending data in its raw format
into cortex data Foundation to keep a
history of all changes in bigquery for
source to Target reconciliation or for
specific reporting use cases such as
time hopping Etc
if cortex CDC processing scripts are
required they will need to run as
frequently as it makes sense for the
data they are processing for example a
table containing a list of countries
will change infrequently but a table
containing records of cells orders will
likely need to get refreshed every few
minutes
setting the processing schedule will
depend on your unique business needs
around performance and cost requirements
and can be configured in the cortex
settings.yaml file there is a default
schedule suggested if you are just
getting started
next the cortex processing scripts will
also require orchestration monitoring
and alerts in case something goes wrong
cortex data Foundation provides
templates that work in Cloud composer a
manage orchestration solution based on
Apache airflow
scripts scheduled in airflow are called
directed acyclic graphs or dags for
short you can also Port the scripts into
other scheduling tools of your choice
for maximum flexibility last but not
least if you are using an integration
tool that may lend data in the Raw data
set with different field names or
formats then what cortex content expects
you can use provided processing scripts
to map the raw data set fields to the
expected name and format in the CDC data
set you can also configure additional
Fields like custom fields and even your
own custom tables or apis depending on
your needs
now that we have reporting ready process
data in our CDC dataset it's time to
configure the reporting layer business
users will access reporting models from
the reporting data set
because the access controls for
reporting data sets are often different
from those where more technical
practitioners work like CDC and row data
sets you may choose to deploy cortex
predefined data models into reporting
data sets in different projects to
manage access and permissions
differently
you can also deploy each workload like
sap or Salesforce into separate data
sets and projects depending on your
needs within the reporting data sets you
have the opportunity to optimize the
reporting models based on your unique
data volume performance and cost
requirements you can choose to have a
bigquery view Computing results every
time it is executed for more lightweight
models or a dag frequently materializing
query results into a table it is also
worth looking into setting up partitions
and clusters for materialized results as
this will reduce the scan volume every
time improving total cost and time spent
for each reporting query you can find
more information and recommendations
about those Topics in the documentation
shown here and Linked In the
descriptions below
as you can see cortex data Foundation
has plenty of options to match your
business requirements and control costs
this can change over time and the
bigquery recommender feature we showed
can help you find the optimal
configuration thanks for watching we
hope you found this overview helpful for
more information please check out the
other videos in this series and explore
links in the descriptions below see you
foreign
[Music]